guys country I mean I Jason for example
has a little farming operation you know
he has one field that's 1600 Acres they
don't they don't make many corners wow
the canola is still really big uh that
kind of thing uh it depends on where
you're at they got a little dry at the
end and it really affected the canola
crop but at the same time if you go to
Tisdale Canada it reminded me a lot of
Oaks North Dakota you know a lot of
still Square it's funny in Saskatchewan
they still talk about miles and they
still talk about Acres sh don't tell
anybody they do yeah oh yeah yeah and uh
they still got to you know follow the
street signs and all that kind of thing
but you know everything's laid out very
similar to North Dakota um they they
don't do as much tiling as they do
around here they haven't got that far
yet and you know very little row crop
there's a few areas of soybeans it's
just you know just that much farther
north and it gets a little colder there
yeah